la foto 10 lei esiste solo così non ha
una faccia lei è così è da tutti ragazzi
benvenuta che sono video sono fuori j
ed oggi siamo swing e il green grid ed
vuol dire che questo è il simulatore dei
papà
oggi i farisei diventerà papà quindi
oggi ragazzi capiremo come si tiene un
figlio per tutti i neo papà del mondo
bene io sto guardando la partita
bellissimo come sappiamo la birra
perfetto perfetto che anche perché è
bello guardare la mia squadra preferita
mentre bevo la birra è fantastico cosa
fa quella ciao donna torna in cucina ma
io e l'obiettivo è quello di guardare la
partita
cos'è tesoro devo fare con quella il mio
figlio ciao figlio devo fare i compiti a
chi devo aiutare
5 perna 5 per 96 x 5 fa 37 per tre fa 21
ma che bravo papà che ti aiutano i
compie fammi tornare a vedere la partita
devo sturare il cesso quindi io devo
fare delle cose in casa e l'obiettivo è
far sì che la barra rossa non aggiunga
al limite fantastico quindi devo suonare
il cesso lo ritroviamo accesso veloci ma
che il gioco è qualcosa che alza sto
cercando va bene ed entrare la partita
moglie aiuta a nostro figlio che che
cuoce la partita e non posso perdermi
dai loro esistere ancora 40 secondi
lascia posso fare sono ubriachi simo dai
figli 1x5 fa 5 perfetto moglie fai
qualcosa stura lo tu adesso sto
guardando la partita lo scavalca tutto
io devo fare ma anche m sono ubriaco o
togliti moglie che già non vedo un cazzo
accusate intasarsi eccesso in un minuto
tesoro dei buttare gli assorbenti qua
dentro porca lei ma lercia mi perdo una
partita
ho vinto round complete
continua quindi l'obiettivo è resistere
tutto questo tempo senza che la barra
rossa vivi al limite e aiutare in casa
nel mentre fantastico figlio devi farli
da soli compiti non posso aiutarti
sempre io che palle 45 che è il perfetto
bene baciare palle figlio matti figli ho
fatto perché non potevo usare il condom
devo cantare ok
perché visto comitato in faccia che
cazzo è una cosa devo cliccare cosa devo
cliccare aiuto sta perdendo tutta la
partita della barca di non accada armi
figlio del cazzo come faccia cosa clicco
a devo cullare che so io non so cullare
i bambini basta
che palle le semi che a queste la
semifinale con la rari quarti di finale
prima adesso c'è la semifinale poi ci
sarà una finale barca erano papa mentre
c'è una partita da distruggere tutto
questo questa scena aveva dell'epico ok
ma suonano alla porta non mi son perso
le azioni perché mia moglie non fa
niente il problema perché forse sono io
in questa casa moglie favo e cosa cazzo
però mi sto perdendo le azioni che bussa
i testimoni di geova a un po di tempo
per parlare di gesù cristo ma [ __ ] quei
goggi go away lo dovevo scrivere mi sei
gol ho perso un golf son perso il gol
che è rassegnato chiellini consegna mai
la donna come sono ubriaco marcio conca
60 secondi raga non ce la farò mai ve lo
dico io cosa cazzo urla questa cosa urli
foto sono ubriachi devo aprire il
barattolo
questo l'ho visto questo l'ho visto gol
facile la pasta fa ma smettila glia
primi cetrioli sottaceto usarli per
qualcosa che vi perdo ricordi per non
sono ubriaco non centra la porta
ragazzi la simulazione di un pezzo è
fantastica e fatta benissimo
ce l'ho fatta ragazzi sono fatto
incredibile ce l'ho fatta a questa volta
che è uomo di famiglia che 6 grazie dio
grazie
beh ragazzi non mi sono perso la
semifinale e adesso c'è la finale
fantastico 300 secondi per resistere mai
così partito subito che è andata a fuoco
la casa parquet male cos'è sta roba
ma porca eva questo sempre a fare i
compiti john file on you tube che che un
file cazzola mattina 9 27 e 36 quanto fa
15 18 36 non fa 36 miss gol non ci
voglio credere ragazzi verso il golf
plus torare il sesso li mortacci sua
maledetti akers che si infiltra nella
tazza del cesso di fate perdere la
partita
toglieteli carcassi non lo guarda la
partita l'ho visto l'ho visto ho visto
il replay va bene perché io devo andare
ad aprire la porta chi è al momento
parlare di gesù cristo piedi a germano
mosconi non capiscano acierno gol ho
capito però perché la porta di una punta
ho perso tutto chi è che chiama la donna
sola vodafone ce la posso fare lega ce
la posso fare bergo tutti gol perde
tutto
madonna riga mi son dovuto fare di birra
per riaggiustare tutta la barra perché
se non solo messo malissimo si è rotto
il tuo 150 secondi siamo a metà si è
rotto il tubo si è rotto il tubo c'è mio
figlio che urla situazione veramente
nervosissima anch'io ragazzo un problema
di fondo io non so cullare i bambini ok
all 1 i testimoni dei geo mag non ho il
momento per pagare vince su cristo hai
rotto a in going to clear so quanto
quanto lungo il messaggio sunray don't
want to vai a merci non voglio comprare
un tappeto magico spiegano il problema
si è rotto il tubo mi sono perso il gol
devi morire qui mi chiedono ancora
qualcosa
gesù cristo programmo tutti i computer
del vaticano ci metto il video di
germano mosconi da da tutti i preti del
vaticano giuro cava si è rotto il tubo
allora che mentre vado a riparare la
caldaia deve succedere di tutto e ve lo
dico io però celo celo celo celo celo
celo c'è veloce moglie che palle che sei
la birra birra francesco totti zia è
rotto il cazzo c'è veramente siglata
rinfilare st marmellata lo dico io da
dare a infilare i testimoni di geova
dagliela loro la marmellata e cazzo ma
per il livello che devo scrivere un
messaggio chilometrico non normale not
io credo nella birra non in dio ho
scritto ma che cazzo
l'ho preso l'ho visto l'ho visto l'ho
visto grande sala 2 o sta andando bene
stavolta non me la voglio tirare a meno
che non facciano un gol in un minuto in
teoria dovremmo essere a posto
uno per 77 triplo 7 madonna che due
palle e rotto veramente la madona zio
matto ammazzo ti ammazzo 2 x 8 16 senti
non hai voglia di andare a scuola non
sei studia un cazzo fai libri come di
youtube che non sanno scrivere ha
segnato io sto andando io sono ubriaco
come lo schifo in terra perfetta una
cannes 150 secondi ragazzi siamo solo a
metà
porca vacca molti problemi chiamati i
pompieri moglie scappati il pompiere non
me ne frega niente ma se vi fa guarda la
partita in un anno ad un giorno le
offerte
le offerte della tim madonna ragazzo
lance ti giuro che non dormo sono a te
non dormo l'ansia di vivere come faccio
a resistere cinque minuti così è
impossibile miglia quante con la
completa
quante cose quanta gente che non per
caso proprio come hanno fatto a
sporcarsi piatti in un secondo
pulisci pulisci veloce pulisci pulisci
l'importante che non si sveglia mio
figlio piccolo che non so cullare io no
vabbè non ci credo in grado di tornare
certo
verso il gol [ __ ] eva figlio figlio
sono ubriaco non vedo le porte da
novanta volta come tua madre 90 madonna
di dio non si può fare la finale in b
giuro che non ne possiedo si può finire
è impossibile dai no no no no no ma
corre corre corre corre
l'ho visto l'ho visto vie rapirla zio
birra oggi però c'è mancano 200 secondi
la città farò mai donna che ragazzi il
progetto dark souls può accompagnare
solo pulisci pulisci polici 120 130
pulirsi quanto tempo dio santo
ok
raga mancano 100 secondi vi giuro che
resistere impossibile e in pose se si
sveglia mio figlio che inizia a urlare
io ho perso perché non lo so non so
cullarlo mio figlio quello di queste si
sveglia mio figlio siamo nella merda rea
hanno fatto sei gol la partita di merda
sei gol un ca ragazzi in questo gioco
c'è tutto c'è al co e parolacce che ha
censurato da tutto il tutto internet
altro che youtube madonna che bordello
beh vive di vendite di beni veloce per
ragazzi testimoni giova non ce la faccio
lo dico non ce la faccia non ci sto
dentro no
ho perso un gol personalmente ho perso
terzo perso perso la giusta la caldaia
ho perso perso non sia giusta non sia
giusta o che sia giusta o perso ha perso
d'ora in cui già detto secondi alla fine
sono ubriaco e 30 secondi alla fine 30
secondi ritagliati moglie di vittoria
tira il cazzo lo penso l'ho perso non ci
posso credere quanto stanno segnalando
visto finale baby se chiodi non farò mai
gol alzati che ci accesso a solare da
sturaro renault 98 cosa arriva a sedermi
su sedermi il culo ai testimoni di geova
siamo forti ce l'ho fatta di fatto ci ho
messo un na'vi non ci posso credere non
mi ricordo l'ultima volta che ho giocato
un gioco così difficile è stato
veramente impossibile bei ragazzi questa
è in green grid ed un gioco bello
difficilissimo però bello mica pensa se
se se scoprivo di non aver registrato
niente che sono riuscito a fare sta roba
epocale e non avrà registrato un cazzo 9
che sono capace di pasti bale
quindi ragazzi spero che vide vi sia
piaciuto spero che abbiate capito che si
fa il papa come al solito servizio
questo momento è un mi piace anche i
vari socio la ricognizione descrizione
se non solo cities che decidiamo non
possiamo vito ragazzi
[Musica]